how are you doing today he's doing great
i'm here with you congratulations on
this film
thank you oh man thank you
not too shabby huh so now this
documentary
it covers it all it's your rise to
stardom your darkest
gaze in the swedish prison and then your
freedom after and kind of taking on this
new pursuit
so why did you decide to do the dock and
was anything off limits for you
no nothing is off limits as you will see
in a moment you know
i think making a documentary is all
about vulnerability and just
truth you know for 2019 you were
released from prison
yes then the following next year the
shutdown happened so you kind of went
from freedom to captivity to freedom to
a shutdown
your mental health must have been really
all over the place what was that that
those last these last three years kind
of been like for you i think i got like
a
i got a head start to the whole
quarantine thing
by the time quarantine happened i was i
was used to it you can't really compare
being confined in prison to like your
home is really two different extremes
so you know um like anybody else you
just take it in stride
you know and keep going i just wanted to
tell my story without really complaining
or
without you know seeming like a victim
or i wanted a pity party or whatnot so
here it is you know there's a lot of
famous faces that appear in this stock
kim kardashian naomi campbell tyler
their creator
another special someone these little
snippet of hair helping you get dressed
what was it like having that support in
this stop featured in this alongside you
with this really important story that
you were gone
i mean it was important having that
support in real life
you know and i think it just shows it
will reveal in the doc you know it's
just how it is in real life it's amazing
and i'm honestly truly blessed
real you know what's next for you as
you're taking this on last question
any music collabs i mean what what
absolutely what's next for me is what i
was doing before i went to prison
being the prettiest mom ever we breaking
headlines and making history with
[Music]
creativity
you